jean-luc Picard is one of Star Trek's
most legendary captains but the man has
a long complicated history with the USS
Enterprise in its crew if you want the
lowdown on his story
then here's Picard's entire timeline
explained a lot of what we know about
John Luke Picard's childhood comes from
family an episode early in the fourth
season of Star Trek the next generation
in which John Luke traumatized from his
time assimilated into the Borg
collective returns to his childhood home
in France John Luke and his older
brother robear helped their father take
care of the family's vineyards but it
didn't take long for John Luke to figure
out that his path led to the Stars he
soon gained a reputation as an
overachiever becoming a sports champion
as well as valedictorian of his high
school president Orion I think he ran
against his father's wishes
John Luke left for Starfleet Academy as
soon as the opportunity arose though it
took him two attempts before his
application was accepted in the sixth
seasons tapestry we learned the events
at Starfleet Academy that left a deepest
mark on him
after getting into a brawl with a group
of Nasik ins over a game of dumb jocks
the card was stabbed through the heart
he survived the injury but he was left
with an artificial organ in his hearts
place we don't have many details about
the cards post Academy life before he
got command of his own ship we learned
in the second season episode the measure
of a man that he once served aboard the
USS reliance but more is known about his
time aboard the USS stargazer there
Picard started as a bridge officer but
he made his way up the ranks the
old-fashioned way being the highest
ranked officer left alive in the middle
of the battle John Luke commanded the
Stargazer for two decades until he and
the surviving crew were forced to
abandon the vessel after a battle with a
Ferengi ship
identify them
that final battle led to the Picard
maneuver being coined for the unorthodox
move jean-luc made to destroy the enemy
vessel more personally relevant to
Picard was his friendship with Jack
crusher aboard the stargazer Jack was
the late husband of Beverly Crusher and
bothered to Wesley both of whom wind up
serving aboard the enterprise its Picard
who while commanding the stargazer sent
Jack crusher on an away mission that led
to his death when we meet the car to the
next generation series premiere he's
already taken command of his famous ship
his order is sent into den net for
beyond which lies the great unexplored
mass of the galaxy on the way there the
enterprise has its first fateful meeting
with the trickster God like alien Q with
a few short breaks here and there the
card remains in command of the
enterprise D until its destruction in
1994 Star Trek generations
Deanna stalwart crew get to explore
quite a bit of that great unexplored
mass and along the way they encounter
aliens both benevolent and hostile
including the fan-favorite board in the
season 2 episode Q who the deceitful Q
uses his powers to send the enterprise
deep into unexplored parts of the galaxy
where they encounter the Borg for the
first time the Borg act as a single
collective mind and rebuff all attempts
at communication in favor of seeking to
overpower the enterprise although
they're eventually returned to
Federation space it's clear the crew
hasn't seen the last of the board since
there were your existence
they will be coming the board re-emerged
in the two-parter the best of both
worlds where they kidnapped Picard and
assimilate him into their collective
Picard is eventually rescued and it
proves the board's Achilles heel as his
connection to the collective allows data
to command the invaders to sleep but
it's clear Picard is severely
traumatized by the experience
this wouldn't be Picard's last encounter
with the Borg however in Eyeborg
the Enterprise crew rescue aboard who
somehow capable of independent thought
they need him again in the two-part
descent as the leader of a group of
liberated Borg resisting the control of
datas twin brother lore and finally the
card would be forced to confront the
Borg and his overwhelming need for
vengeance against them in 1996's Star
Trek first contact when the aliens
attempt to assimilate the Federation by
going back in time before the
Federation's founding one of the most
interesting relationships on Star Trek
The Next Generation is the kinship that
develops between Picard and the Android
data by the end of the series and the
subsequent films it's clear Picard holds
the Android close to his heart he sees
data as at the very least a close friend
however at times their connection
doesn't seem all that different than
that between a father and a son the card
reveals part of his fascination with an
admiration for data in the second season
episode the measure of a man
data attempts to resign his commission
so that an insistent Starfleet scientist
can't run experiments on him which will
wipe out his memory the scientists
argues data as a machine doesn't have
the right to resign his commission and
Picard assumes the difficult task of
proving that data is a sentient being
with the right to make his own choices
and not be subjected to anyone elses
ownership the card famously tells the
presiding judge get on a stop it was
founded to seek out new life well there
it says data is tragically forced to
sacrifice himself at the end of the
final next generation film 2002's Star
Trek nemesis though it's hinted he could
return in a new form when the card is
appointed as arbiter of succession by
the dying Klingon Chancellor Kim Peck he
helps alter the course of the Klingon
Empire as arbiter the carts job is to
weigh the worth of the two
challengers Gowron and do Rus by the end
of season fours reunion
Kim Peck is dead and no new chancellor
has been officially announced things get
even more complicated when Worf claiming
vengeance for the death of his mates
kale are at do Ross's hands transports
over to Ross's ship and kills him the
card finally announces Garen as the
rightful Chancellor but to Klingon
sisters from the house of Duras appear
with a boy named Tora who they claim is
the son of Duras and should therefore be
considered a challenger in the right the
card later confirms Torrell is the son
of Duras but that he is too young and
inexperienced to be considered
Chancellor the decision pushes the
Klingon Empire into open civil war
eventually the house of Duras is
conspiracy with the Romulans is exposed
and Garin presides over a reunited
Empire as an added benefit Worf and his
house are redeemed in the eyes of his
people in spite of their respective
series being separated by two decades
jean-luc Picard proves to be an
important figure in the life of spa the
first time Picard significantly touches
Spock's life is in the third seasons
Sara Spock himself doesn't appear but
his father CEREC towards the enterprise
to negotiate a trade deal with alla
garin's unfortunately it soon becomes
clear that CEREC suffers from a rare
degenerative disorder that causes his
emotions to run wild the card agrees to
a mind meld
so that CEREC can maintain enough
control to continue with the
negotiations hi mine - you're in the -
park unification the card comes face to
face with Spock himself he sent to
Romulus to find spa because Starfleet
fears the Vulcan may have defected to
their rivals instead the cart learns
Spock is involved in secret negotiations
with the hopes of bringing the Vulcan
and Romulan people back together by the
end of the two-parter
Sarek finally succumbs to his illness
and unification ends with a
compassionate and tender gesture on the
cards part he allows Spock to mind-meld
with him so that Spock may connect with
the parts of his father that the card
had experienced of all of the Star Trek
series of the past six decades
can boast as inventive or satisfying a
finale as all good things the final
episode of the next generation cue
causes the card to jump both backwards
and forwards in time so that the story
takes place in the present past and
decades in the future where the card is
an older man suffering from a
degenerative mental disease the cards
trips to the future are particularly
difficult with future visions of Beverly
Crusher data and Geordi LaForge
all aware of his condition it makes it
that much more challenging to convince
anyone in that time that he is actually
experiencing what he says he's
experiencing I know what you're thinking
it's the aerobatic syndrome he's
beginning to lose his mind the old man
but it's not that and I'm not
daydreaming either none of the TNG
movies hinted towards the illness
beginning to emerge and the future of
the episode was only one possible
timeline but with a much older jean-luc
appearing in Star Trek Picard
it's possible the syndrome may finally
rear its ugly head when the next
generation crew gets on the big screen
for the first time in 1994 Star Trek
generations it sadly comes with death of
William Shatner as Captain Kirk and
unfortunately jean-luc Picard suffers
some much more personal losses both in
the beginning and at the end of the
game-changing film
early in generations the enterprise's
empathic counselor Deanna Troi since is
something is terribly wrong and when she
finds Captain Picard flipping through a
photo album jean-luc reveals he's just
received news that his brother repair
and his family have been killed in a
fire without a wife or children of his
own the loss has Picard lamenting on the
likelihood that he'll be the last one in
his family line I've come to feel that
there was a supposed
by the end of the movie the card loses
the enterprise itself the ship barely
survives a battle with a Klingon
bird-of-prey run by the villainous
sisters Lursa and better the crew
evacuates to the ship's saucer section
which crashes on the surface of Veridian
3 thankfully as Picard predicts the
enterprise-d won't be the last ship to
carry the name enterprise the final big
screen appearance of Gianluca card comes
with 2002 s Star Trek nemesis the
enterprise is sent to Romulus to meet
the Romulan empires new leader who we
soon learn has an unexpected connection
to Picard as it turns out praetor
Shinzon is a clone of jean-luc
the Romulans cloned the captain in hopes
of one day replacing him with their own
identical agents but when one of the
Empire's many power shifts took place
the clone was sent to a labor colony
with the enslaved people of Remus
Shinzon lures Picard to Romulus because
the cloning process that created him is
now killing him and his only potential
cure is a complete blood transfusion
with Picard ultimately Shinzon's plans
to kill the card and destroy the
Federation or foiled and the clone
villain dies fighting his older
counterparts on top of all that nemesis
includes huge shifts in the cards life
including the loss of Riker as his
number one we learn early in the film
that Riker is finally taking the
captain's chair on the USS Titan and his
new wife Deanna Troi is coming with him
the card means for data to replace Riker
as his first officer but the Android
sacrifices himself to save his friends
in the final battle an anticipation of
Star Trek Picard
IDW released the prequel miniseries Star
Trek Picard countdown the story takes
place six years after the events of
nemesis 14 years before Picard the card
is an admiral commanding the USS Verity
Romulus star is close to going supernova
and the Romulan Empire abandons some of
its usual paranoia and secrecy for
Starfleet's help unfortunately
complications arise when Picard travels
to the Romulan city of you yacht beta
the Romulans there have enslaved the
native population and neglected to tell
Starfleet because in the words of one of
the
colonies Romulan leaders evacuating them
would be as ridiculous as evacuating the
rocks and trees when the card refuses to
relocate the Romulans without the
natives the colony's leaders take him
and his first officer prisoner countdown
gives us a chance to see Rafi Muscat sir
the irreverent first officer who insists
on referring to Picard is Jael in action
as Picard's second in command during the
Romulan evacuation we also meet the
Romulans jabón and lares while they're
still Tal Shiar agents and it's revealed
exactly how they eventually come to work
for and live with the card years before
the events of Star Trek the card the
titular hero convinces the Federation to
help the Romulans evacuate their home
star system because of an impending
supernova the Federation pulls out of
the evacuation after a band of rogue
synthetics attacks Mars and Picard
resigns from Starfleet and protests 14
years later we find the card still
mourning the loss of data and utterly
disillusioned with Starfleet and the
Federation the galaxy was mourning
burying its dead and stop life from its
duties after a young woman named Dodge
approaches the card for help the former
captain of the enterprise
finds himself back in the thick of
things he's embroiled in a conspiracy
involving an ancient secret Romulan
cabal and scientist Bruce Maddox who
tried and failed to get permission to
use data as a lab rat twily no longer
has the enterprise at his command the
card blasts off into the void with a new
band of friends who redefine the word
ragtag and while they're not in his crew
anymore
we get the chance to see old friends
like data Riker Troi and even Star Trek
voyagers seven of nine check out one of
our newest videos right here plus even
more looper videos about your favorite
movies and TV shows are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
you
[Music]